ein italienisches forschungsteam hat
einen rund 20 kilometer breiten see
unter dem eis des mars süd aufgespürt
mit flüssigem wasser weil könnte es dort
leben geben wie genau diese spektakuläre
entwicklung gelangen um ob es auch schon
konkrete hinweise auf außerirdisches
leben gibt das alles jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen die
planeten mars saturn und jupiter gelten
alle schon seit längerer zeit als
äußerst aussichtsreiche orte in unserem
sonnensystem auf denen bzw deren monden
außerirdisches leben vermutet wird und
die fahndung läuft auf hochtouren
wir hatten darüber berichtet erst vor
kurzem hatte der mars rover curiosity
eine spannende entdeckung in dem jahr
milliarden altem gestein des mars
gemacht organischer materie nämlich also
sehr einfache kohlenstoffverbindungen
die hinweise auf eine lebensfreundliche
zeit auf dem roten planeten geben
möglicherweise hat es dort also mal von
mikroben nur so gewimmelt zudem hatte
der nasa war auch eine
methankonzentration in der mars luft
festgestellt die stark schwankt auf der
erde entsteht methan durch biologische
prozesse beispielsweise wenn rinder ihre
nahrung verdauen
jetzt gibt es eine weitere wirklich
spektakuläre entdeckung auf dem mars ein
forschungsteam aus bologna hat gleich
einen ganzen see aus flüssigem wasser
entdeckt und zwar rund 1,5 kilometer
unter dem eis das master puls die iraner
daten vom mars express der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa zeigen dies und
zwar in der südpolregion des roten
planeten planung ausstrahle die daten
zeigen in dieser akte grenzen region
dieselben signaturen wie sehen unter dem
eis in polar regionen der erde
sie zeigen und den unterirdischen seen
wie beispielsweise dem lake willens in
der antarktis wimmelt es nur so von
mikroben bedeutet das etwa dass die
existenz von leben auch in diesem
gletschersee des mars eine klare sache
ist flüssiges wasser ist schließlich die
grundvoraussetzung für leben wie wir es
kennen
die fachwelt ist sich weiterhin nicht
sicher denn darauf geben die radar
beobachtungen keine direkten hinweise an
der südpolregion des roten planeten ist
es
deutlich kälter als in den
unterirdischen seen der erde
bei minus 68 grad celsius soll die
temperatur des jetzt entdeckten maß sees
liegen dass das wasser flüssig ist liegt
nach vermutung des forschungsteams an
einem hohen salzgehalt natrium magnesium
und kalium salze die sowieso häufig auf
dem mars anzutreffen sind könnten den
gefrierpunkt des sees deutlich
herabgesetzt haben eine derart hohe
salzkonzentration mache es für mögliches
leben in dem maß wasser nicht gerade
einfach doch ein ausschlusskriterium ist
dies nach ansicht des forschungsteams
nicht denn auch auf der erde gibt es
mikroorganismen die mit einer hohen
salzkonzentration zurechtkommen ein
weiterer unterschied zu dem irdischen
see der antarktis ist übrigens dass der
leg willens in der antarktis kein
abgeschlossenes ökosystem ist denn ein
unterirdischer fluss sorgt dafür dass
das wasser regelmäßig ausgetauscht wird
jedenfalls sei mit dieser entdeckung
jetzt eine jahrelange diskussion beendet
so das fazit der amerikanischen
gesellschaft zur förderung der
wissenschaften die auch die aktuelle
studie der italienischen forscherinnen
und forscher in ihrem fachblatts science
veröffentlicht hat denn bisher hatte man
auf dem markt nur winzige spuren von
flüssigem wasser aufspüren können
beispielsweise hatten sich auf dem nas
lande modul phoenix wassertropfen
niedergeschlagen zudem hatte man auch
strukturen an den polkappen entdeckt die
von eis stammen könnten ein weiteres
indiz in der äußerst dünnen luft des
mars befindet sich auch ein geringer
anteil an wasserdampf ja das war es aber
auch bisher an hinweisen dennoch hatten
einige forschungsteam schon seit rund 30
jahren spekuliert dass unter den
polkappen als flüssiges wasser
existieren könnte vergleichbar mit den
unterirdischen seen auf der erde gelegen
in grönland und der antarktis
hundertprozentig sicher waren sich die
forschungsteams allerdings bislang nur
dass es mal vor milliarden jahren wasser
gegeben haben muss denn darauf weisen
ausgetrocknete sedimente und flussläufe
hin und so wurde in den letzten jahren
eigentlich diskutiert gibt es auf dem
mars flüssiges wasser oder nicht hatte
vielleicht sogar mal ein ganzer ozean
den mars vor langer zeit bedeckt bislang
waren das alles spekulationen die durch
diese entdeckung jetzt
wissenschaftliches fundament bekommen
haben
und das forschungsteam ist sich ziemlich
sicher dass dieser eine unterirdische
sie kein einzelfall auf dem mars ist
denn bisher ist wohl nur ein kleiner
teil der südpol kappe untersucht worden
deswegen sei es durchaus wahrscheinlich
dass unterirdisches flüssiges wasser
auch an anderer stelle vorkommen
ich denke dass er der entdeckung von
leben im weltall wirklich immer näher
kommen ich bin wirklich extrem gespannt
wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr
die na ja etwas unzuverlässige abo boxee
auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen andern täglich und
garantieren einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue
indizien ja es gibt immer mehr hinweise
also bis dann bleibt dran